please welcome back with aaron and ben
napier
my heroes and ben um i am very excited
to hear from you and erin tell us what
you are doing because i want to know
some thrifty holiday like tips well
aaron's laughing here because like this
is normally her world but i am the
christmas king it's true oh so i don't
know y'all were just watching he tries
to go full griswold every year every
like this right here
if this could be our house at christmas
not quite enough they went all out so
that's that's me that's how i
like to do christmas i go a little more
understated yeah erin likes uh she likes
white lights i like this very much this
is classic aaron christmas this is
pretty classic so if you have if you
have a yard that has some greenery that
you can clip from the yard or some
little tiny trees maybe in your woods
you could pot at the front door and then
wrap in some christmas lights it doesn't
cost anything to use what you already
have or if you have like some pre-lit
christmas trees the lights don't work
anymore you could just cut the top off
plop it in a little pot by the door but
you can get things like you can get
little uh
little lights like a at a pharmacy and
uh or a dollar store but look at this so
you can buy these letters cut out at a
at a you know craft store or you can cut
them out yourself but everybody has this
scraps like old t-shirts your kids old
christmas jammies the ones that they
never liked very much and you're not
gonna cry when you pack in a box well we
have someone i mean
um chan she's actually here she has a
question um for you guys and we have a
little back story take a look
hi joe it's yvonne
i have the sad house on the block
especially when it comes to front door
decorations it can be expensive and it's
hard to know how to get it just right do
you have any tips for me
hi ivan yvonne's here
you're like giving me like
chanel
meets christmas yeah i'm liking it um
okay erin what is your first tip um yes
i love what ben was saying when you're
like decorating the outside of your door
yeah this is just a fun
super inexpensive thing because
everybody has old like clothes t-shirts
you could cut this fabric take these
letters
wrap them in the fabric take some glue
and you glue it on and this is what they
look like yeah and then it's a cute
little banner
but then you see this like this is
it's crafty so it's not like let's show
you how we use it it's not like over the
top yeah so then you can just like hang
it outside your door oh my gosh okay
that is so awesome
[Applause]
it's sweet but aaron's got an idea so
look at this yes now this goes classy
this does go classy you can clip some
bells
or galvanized buckets
and you put bells on twine
hang it inside your
bell bucket
um and then you can attach it to like
greenery you've clipped out of the yard
and use this instead of a wreath hang on
the front door oh beautiful sounds real
festive when people come in yeah aaron
and i are really big on clipping things
out of the yard because it's free
um
but also you get the like
it makes you look like you're those
people that care a lot when you like
make fresh arrangements
[Applause]
yeah
i love that yeah we've got a nice little
mix
of both here you got you know some
classy little trees you got a little bit
of a
little bit of loud and bombastic and
then you got the classy bales with the
clippings from the yard i could really
think of resonates with everybody yeah
you know you can't go wrong and i
sincerely that's why you're the
tastemakers of america now
thank you
you just you know
forbes like power couple of the globe
taste makers that is absolutely what it
is and people magazine's highest selling
issue um
i think you're on the cover twice too
which is oh well unheard of in the space
you're just starting that it is
50 sexiest men alive
everyone telling people
that little detail because there's only
50 of us alive
william shatner was ahead of him though
so
well erin i think you know you're on the
most beautiful absolutely and you too
yvonne and we're gonna send these items
home with you
so that you can
get your decorating on
and i can't thank you enough ben and
aaron and yvonne for
talking about just little things we can
do to boost our mood this is that mental
wellness that is that joy if you can
come home and see something you did that
will spark that joy and make you feel
good and express yourselves to your
community
this is very meaningful honestly i take
it real serious
absolutely
you always got me crying man
make sure you check out the new season
of hometown and hometown ben's holiday
workshop premiering sunday december 26th
on hgtv i'll be watching
[Music]